[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new black panther to
video there are a bunch of Easter eggs
and teasers inside the Black Widow
trailer and even though that movie is
set during the past it's also setting up
story for new movies after avengers
endgame in present day and Marvel phase
4 so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing an Amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave all your theories about black
panther 2 on the video thankfully black
panther 2 is one of the few movies that
has not been shut down or delayed by the
virus that's been happening lately curly
the movies coming out May 20-22 and is
set to open Marvel phase 5 in a really
big way that's when we're really going
to start seeing a lot of the new Fox
x-men characters rebooted inside the MCU
the Fantastic Four characters all the
big stuff that everyone's hyped about
but we actually see some black panther
stuff happening during the Black Widow
trailer so during the Black Widow
trailer that they released just a little
while ago we all saw the taskmaster has
a set of gloves that look like they're
made from the same vibranium material
that black panther's suits are made of
and his claws are also probably
vibranium metal you see him used some of
Black Panthers fighting moves we see him
watching footage of all the Avengers so
no wonder he's able to copy all their
abilities but the Black Widow movie also
takes place around the same time as the
Black Panther movie was happening right
after Captain America's Civil War but
before Avengers infinity war just for
reference that was a two-year period
because that's how long Hawkeye and
ant-man were under house arrest oh hey
guys my two years up already in the
Black Widow movie might be set during
the past but Marvel is still using it to
set up new Marvel phase 4 story a really
good example is the weapons Plus program
that's actually Thunderbolt Ross's name
for the Super Soldier Serum program in
present day recently before the big
virus outbreak they screen some new
footage of the Falcon and Winter Soldier
series during a Disney investor meeting
and during that footage Falcon and
Winter Soldier referenced the weapons
Plus program so it's not a big stretch
to see taskmaster with his black panther
gear and copied fighting moves and a
couple of other black panther to Easter
eggs in the Black Widow trailer implying
that some of taskmasters plans involve
things that will cross over into black
panther 2 in present day and if it
wasn't clear black panther
we'll take place after Avengers endgame
the only new movies that are coming out
right now but are set during the past or
the Black Widow movie and the Eternals
movie but the Eternals movie is kind of
doing the same thing as the first Wonder
Woman movie did where some of the movie
is set in present day and some of it is
set during the past tell their ancient
origin story most of those characters
are thousands of years old the exception
is kit harington's Black Knight
character he is just like a normal
person that's alive in present day we'll
talk more about that when they dropped
the Eternals trailer also recently in
real life just before the big virus
outbreak Angela Bassett who plays
remonda Black Panthers mother revealed
that Sheree is also building Black
Panther a new suit for Black Panther 2
this is the clip of her talking about
that everything instead of Black Panther
2 by the way you were telling me
backstage that they decided to change
the costume of Black Panther I was
telling you that in confidence
lets them just hyping up the new tech
that Black Panther is going to be using
during Black Panther 2 no surprise he
would get a big upgrade for that new
movie just look at Iron Man in all of
his movies he gets multiple new suits
sometimes in his new movies mostly for
the purposes of selling new toys but
also because the villain of each movie
poses some new challenge that their old
armor isn't up to the task that was the
whole reason sure he gave Black Panther
his most recent nano vibranium armor she
made fun of him for how old the suit was
how he had to climb into it like a
regular pair of pants and put the helmet
on with his slow reaction time don't
freeze the nano armor was intended to
solve that issue by being instantaneous
and connected to his brain through a
neural link with this version of the
armor all he has to do is just think
what he wants it to do in the armor will
do it she also added the charge ability
that allows it to absorb energy for
later use that was the cool secret
function there have been a lot of rumors
about who the villain of Black Panther 2
is Namor Doctor Doom I don't know if any
of those rumors are true
but I would love to see them use major
new Fox Marvel characters rebooted in
the MCU like storm would be amazing in
Black Panther 2 in fun fact had they
made the first x-men movie a couple
years earlier before they did Angela
Bassett would have made an amazing
version of storm in that movie most of
you saw the black widow trailer footage
and were wondering where taskmaster
would have gotten all that raw vibranium
to make his gloves and claws from and
where he would have gotten the knowledge
of how to make the vibranium a weave
cloth assuming that he fashioned that
gear before the events of the Black
Widow movie that would have also been
before ulysses klaw was killed by kill
monger ulysses klaw one of the leading
sources of illegal vibranium sales in
the world so that's an easy place for
taskmaster to buy his vibranium but it's
difficult at best to fashioned vibranium
into shields like Captain America shield
into basic melee weapons but black
panther in the wakandans have been
working with vibranium for so long that
they've learned how to make their
clothing in fabrics out of vibranium
how would taskmaster gained the
knowledge of how to do that if not from
another spy inside Wakanda or a traitor
that he had been able to turn or
brainwash because remember the Black
Widow program is all about conditioning
and brainwashing them into becoming
soldiers then everyone saw this Black
Widow here and just assumed that she was
another russian girl given to the Black
Widow program as a child and she just
happened to be of African descent but if
you zoom in enhanced look at the tribal
tattoos on her face they're similar to
the tribal tattoos you see on the faces
of some of the wakandans in the Black
Panther movie so it's possible that she
was born of a Condon in bears that same
special vibranium tattoo inside her lip
that allows her to get into Wakanda in
at some point in her childhood
taskmaster had her abducted and
brainwashed her to become a black widow
so that he could infiltrate Wakanda and
gain access to their secrets and
Technology and if you look at this room
here with this bank of monitors behind
them this is actually inside that giant
tower that they blow up later in the
Black Widow trailer the building where
natasha is fighting taskmaster then she
jumps out and he chases her through the
air with a comic-book sword these
monitors depict major foreign cities
where black widows are currently running
missions one of them looks like Wakanda
it's just another example of how even
though Black Widow takes place in the
past and the movie is all about Natasha
trying to end the Black Widow program
the movie is still connected to the
other new Marvel movies that are coming
up in small ways in talking more about
Black Panther 2 in his new vibranium
suit that he's going to get another
reason to upgrade to a new
suit is because the world now knows most
of his secrets after the events of the
Black Panther movie where he made it a
point to being open about their culture
in their technology with the rest of the
world so you have to imagine by the time
Black Panther 2 picks up most of the
world knows what's going on with Black
Panther and once everyone knows your
secret you no longer have that big
advantage and you have to adapt another
good example of that is that during Iron
Man 2 rody took Iron Man's old mark2
suit in the military repurposed it into
the war machine suits even though
they're best friends iron man does like
to make fun of Rhodey saying that he
always wears his 80s hand-me-down suits
but that's only because every time
Rhodey upgrades his war machine armor so
does Iron Man so that he can stay on the
bleeding edge of technology black
panther 2 would be doing the exact same
thing with Charice help staying on the
bleeding edge of technology each new
movie something way more advanced to
deal with whatever new challenge the
villain poses it also happens in all the
spider-man movies too that's why he
builds his new suit during spider-man
far from home and he'll probably get
another new suit that he'll build
himself during spider-man 3 if it's
gonna be open season on spider-man
during spider-man 3 because of what
Mysterio did with the help of Jay jonah
Jameson the stealth suits from the
comics would do spider-man some good the
only other big Easter eggs we have right
now for Black Panther 2 are that scene
from Avengers end game where a co a is
talking about the underwater earthquake
off the coast of Africa that happens to
be in the same location marked on Nick
Fury's map at the end of Iron Man 2
reading all those tremors it was a mild
subduction under the African plate do we
have a visual how are we handling it net
it's a quick under the ocean we handle
it by not handling it since Nick Fury's
map was referencing Atlantis when a Koi
a brushes off that underwater earthquake
like the wakandans don't care about
underwater earthquakes why would we
bother helping out that's a good way to
set up future drama between Namor and
black panther for an eventual battle in
the movies that mirrors their fights in
the comics what are the major beeps
between Namor and Black Panthers that
they're both kings of their people
they're responsible for the well-being
of their Nations and after a couple
major comic-book disasters Wakanda winds
up sacking Atlantis the name were in the
Atlanteans revenge sack Wakanda
so movie name or could be pissed that
black panther's people didn't lend the
Atlanteans any aid during Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame and
just treat that like an act of hostility
turning into open war in a future Black
Panther movie anymore hasn't been
confirmed as the villain to Black
Panther 2 but there's so many Namor
Easter eggs that we've gotten so far
hopefully they'll do him at some point
in the movies
everyone post all your theories about
what they're gonna be doing during Black
Panther 2 and who you want the villain
to be congratulations to the winner for
my last big giveaway mr. serious a B
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details
everyone click here for my new Deadpool
3 marvel video and click here for that
new mandalorian season 2 teaser for
ahsoka tano thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight